-Our first guest tonight i
a talented actor and comedian.
You know him from
his work on "Community"
and films such as "The Hangover"
and "Crazy Rich Asians."
You can see him on the hit
series "The Masked Singer,
which airs
Wednesday nights on Fox.
Please welcome back
to the show Ken Jeong.
How are you, Ken?
-Fine. How are you doing?
Thank you for having me,
brother.
Appreciate it.
-It's always a delight
to see you.
And I do want to talk
about your show,
which is always joyous
and a show that I think
a lot of people watch together
watch with their families.
But I also want to give yo
a moment
to address what a difficult time
this has been,
not just for all of us
but hyper specifically,
the Asian-American community
-Yes. Thank you so much, Seth.
And, yeah, just with regar
to the situation in Atlant
and the shootings in Atlanta
my heart, thoughts, and prayer
go out to all affected.
And a special shout-out
to Karen Chi, your writer,
who really had
a very, very eloquent piec
on the day that it happened.
It was very moving.
And it is just a sign
that, you know,
with the Asian-American
community, enough is enough.
We're just fed up.
And the study that Karen cited
on your show a few days ago,
anti-Asian-American crime
has risen almost 150%
in the last year.
And in that same study,
overall hate crime went down 7%.
And this is precisely due to
weaponizing
terms like "China virus"
and "kung flu" and --
and also the fact that even in
this particular crime,
there is debate whether this
crime was racially motivated
Asian-American women
are two times as likely
to be assaulted in America
This was clearly, clearly
racially motivated.
This was clearly a hate crime.
And it -- You know, as a guy
who used to be a doctor
and whose wife is still
practicing medicine,
I have an idea of
how to solve COVID.
It's mask, vaccination,
common sense,
don't be an ass[bleep].
You know, but I think that -
I don't --
as a human, I don't know
how to solve racism.
You know?
It's so -- It --
It takes listening, learning
loving, being tolerant.
But you know --
But it really starts off,
in just our particular cas
as Asian-Americans,
this kung flu [bleep]
has to stop.
And we really
need to express that loudly.
And we are.
And thank you, man.
I thank you for letting me -
letting me express that.
-Of course.
Thank you for sharing
those thoughts.
You know, one thing which is
often spoken about
in the entertainment industr
especially,
is how important
representation is
and how, you know,
that can bridge the gap
insofar as you have people
who are racist
who maybe never see differen
races in positive lights.
-Right.
-And you must appreciate -
last time you were here wa
season one of
"The Masked Singer."
This was a show that you -
I believe, if my memory serves
your mother was a fan of
the Korean version of the show
-Yeah.
I mean, it really is --
and this is not --
this is less a plug for my sho
than it is --
it is nice to be on a show
where you can, you know --
and we're one of several -
that you can just kind of
take a break
and be silly for a second,
you know, and just escape
the realities of it.
And in this day and age,
I mean, I think that's wha
entertainment has evolved to
Because, you know, there is --
there is value
in what you're doing right now
especially you.
You know, like merging,
you know, political though
and comedy and entertainment
And myself, I'm merging
just kind of, you know,
my essence as a former physician
and as an overactor, I guess
I guess my overacting
is somehow -- You know what?
We're just sick of people
who do it well.
-Right.
-Who act.
And you know,
it's just good to have --
-It's a thriving time
for overactors.
-Yes, it's a thriving time
for overactored, fractured
non-talents such as myself
-[ Laughs ]
-It's just nice to have a --
have a say
in the verse of song that is -
-Now, you actually --
So, you went --
And, again, congratulations.
You're in season five
of this show.
It's a runaway hit.
But you went back and you did --
you appeared on --
this is the original
"Masked Singer" in Korea
that you were the --
you sang as the Golden Pig
-Yes.
2019 was the Year of the Pig
And they asked me --
a shout-out to Craig Plestis
who is the showrunner of
American "Masked Singer."
He said, "We'd love for yo
to go to Korea to promote it."
And I went to Korea in, yeah
around 2019
to just -- like, under secrecy
No one knew.
I was in my hotel room,
just like
in the American "Masked Singer
here,
where you have to be
in a hotel room
and really just be completel
offline and off the grid.
So I was there in Korea fo
three days in my hotel room.
Like, under a mask,
went straight to the studio,
performed,
really got an idea
of what the contestants
on the show do.
And it's like they stuck m
in a small --
it reminded me of my
college dorm room at Duke.
It was just, like,
a little twin bed.
And it was just me.
And just -- I'm rehearsing
Radiohead's "Creep" ad nauseam
And it's something
I would just do all the time
like doing karaoke.
It's like my go-to 'oke song
And I just went out there
completely nervous,
and it was -- Yeah,
it was really surreal.
I got a deep appreciation
of what the contestants
on the show do.
It's a shout-out to all th
contestants who do it.
It's incredibly hard.
It's a lot easier,
again, to overact
and to be stupid
and, you know, to be --
It's so much more difficul
than my lane.
-First of all, I like that
like everyone who went to Duke
you've managed
to subtly drop it in.
And I just want you to kno
how much I appreciate that
-What?
Just because I graduated
like 1990 with a
bachelor of science in zoology
and it came very organically
off the tip of my tongue,
and it's from there I got into
UNC med school
and then had a career in,
like, internal medicine
for seven years at an HMO
here in Southern Californi
and then jetéed over
to "Knocked Up,"
directed by Judd Apatow,
my first role,
and then had my own eponymou
show called "Dr. Ken,"
and somehow you think
I shoehorned it?
-Going a little long?
-Who are you talking --
[ Laughter ]
What are you doing?
You're telling people
to cut me off
just because I got dewed on you,
dawg.
How dare you.
-Thank you for that.
'Cause I think Wikipedia is down
across the nation.
So that's really helpful.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, but here's my --
I have a serious question.
How -- Ken,
I apologize if I'm --
So, obviously,
on "The Masked Singer,"
when you did
the South Korean version,
how famous are you there?
Were people very excited
when they saw you?
-[ Laughs ]
You know, it was kind of -
I think I'm kinda sorta.
You know, I think I'm
kinda sorta famous there.
They were -- Because when -- And
I knew that, going in.
So I think there's
a level of familiarity,
but not intense fame.
And so when I did sing,
and then you hear what
the judges are saying,
they're saying,
"This is Jack Black.
This is like someone amazing
like Jack Black."
When I revealed myself, it was
not like "Who is this guy?
Oh, we kinda sorta know
it's Ken."
But it's like "Oh,
it's not Jack Black."
[ Laughter ]
It was a little bit of
like, "No, you're good.
We know who you are.
And credit to you.
Good job. Good on you.
But we kinda wanted Jack Black."
-Did you tell them that
Jack Black didn't go to Duke
-I did.
And I explained why.
And they cut everything.
And I said, "How dare you?
Jack Black never went to Duke,
never had a bachelor of scienc
in zoology,
never went to the University --"
and so on and so on.
-I think we're all
familiar with it now.
-I think we're all familia
with the story.
-Hey, first of all,
it is very --
I think it's very exciting
that there is a "Kensday"
in our week right now.
-[ Laughs ]
-I want to congratulate yo
on that.
-I really -- this intervie
doesn't happen
if you're not contractuall
obligated to say "Kensday,
so I appreciate that.
-Made it.
-It's part of my rider.
It's also part of
my "Room Raiders"
deep-dive background there
So, yeah, it's very importan
that you bring it up.
-Ken, congrats on the show
It's always a pleasure
to see you.
Thanks so much for being her
and helping provide contex
in these trying times.
And next time,
I look forward to
doing in it person.
-Absolutely. Thank you, brother.
Thank you so much.